No pude usar mi casillero en semanas porque la cerradura
me recordaba a la que había puesto en mi boca
cuando el vagabundo en la calle
me miraba buscando solo
una afirmación de que él era digno de ver.
Yo me preocupaba más por mi aparato de la manzana
que por darle una a él esa mañana.
Cuando una señora en la gala por fondos me dijo:
"Estoy orgullosa de ti.
Debe ser duro enseñar a esos niños tontos y pobres",
la respuesta la guarde en un sobre, porque necesitábamos el dinero
más de lo que los chicos necesitaban su honra.
Pasamos tanto tiempo
escuchando las cosas que las personas están diciendo
que rara vez prestamos atención a las cosas que no dicen.
El silencio es residuo del miedo.
Es sentir tus defectos,
es morderte la lengua.
Es el aire que se retira de tu pecho
porque no se siente seguro en tus pulmones.
El silencio es el genocidio de Ruanda. El silencio es Katrina.
Es lo que se escucha cuando ya no hay más bolsas para cadáveres.
Es el sonido después de que la soga ya está tensa.
Es el quemar. Son las cadenas. Es el privilegio. Es el dolor.
No hay tiempo para elegir tus batallas
cuando tus batallas ya te han elegido.
No voy a dejar que el silencio se envuelva en torno a mi indecisión.
Le diré a Christian que es un león,
un santuario de la valentía y brillantez.
Le preguntaré al vagabundo su nombre
y cómo le fue en su día, porque a veces
lo único que todos queremos es ser humanos.
Le diré a esa señora que mis alumnos pueden hablar
del trascendentalismo como si fuesen Thoreau,
y solo porque has visto un episodio de "The Wire"
no significa que sepas algo acerca de mis chicos.
Así que este año,
en lugar de renunciar a algo,
voy a vivir cada día como si hubiera un micrófono
escondido debajo de mi lengua,
un escenario en la parte inferior de mi inhibición.
Porque, ¿quién necesita una palestra
cuando lo único que se necesita es la voz nuestra?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)